let's talk about let's talk about
Halloween as of tonight you have just
four days to find your inappropriately
sexy costume
whether it's sexy Barney the Dinosaur or
a sexy candy corn or as Playboy's
website recently featured and I swear to
you this is true
a sexy John Oliver costume to look like
a sexy me and the worst thing is there's
more than one photo I don't know if I've
ever been as confused as I am right now
although I'm pretty sure that I'm not as
confused as louis c.k is about his sexy
doppelganger that's also real now at
this point let's agree sexy Halloween
costumes have simply gone too far but it
doesn't matter because we all know what
Halloween is really about candy sweet
sugar treats this Halloween Americans
will spend 2.2 billion dollars on candy
although to be fair that does include
Necco wafers which might be better
classified as coagulated dust but but is
it really fair to describe sugar as a
treat considering how much we eat it all
year round today the average American
consumes 22 teaspoons of sugar a day
three times what we need that's equal to
75 pounds of sugar a year for every man
woman and child in the United States
holy
75 pounds of sugar that's like eating
Michael Sarah's weight and sugar every
single year what that's a little less
than it was in the late 90s it's still
pretty incredible so let's talk about
sugar everyone loves it and it turns out
that's because we are genetically
programmed to Eric's dice a
neuroscientist at the Oregon Research
Institute is using functional MRI
scanners to learn how our brains respond
to sweetness sugar activates a brain in
a special way that's very reminiscent of
you know drugs like cocaine sugar
activates our brains like cocaine and
I've got to say Scarface would have been
a very different movie
if it ended without Pacino sitting in a
chair took it out of his mind on baked
goods say hello to my little jam we
shook out being so viscerally appealing
to us it's frankly no wonder that food
manufacturers put it in everything and I
do mean everything about 35% of the
sugars that Americans consume come from
beverages but we're also talking about
salad dressings and ketchup in you know
breads and cereals and crackers and the
list goes on and on even to beef in
Turkey turkey we have no idea how
prevalent sugar is in almost everything
that we eat look at Clamato juice the
original tomato cocktail with clam what
one serving has 11 grams of sugar in it
so they clearly thought well look let's
improve the taste by adding sugar
instead of thinking let's improve the
taste by removing the cloud would be a
problem were it not for the fact that as
we all know excess sugar is probably not
good for us both the World Health
Organization and the American Heart
Association have warned against the
harms of eating too much of it and some
studies suggest that too much sugar can
literally mess with the brain this rat
is perfectly healthy put him in a vat of
water and he finds his way to safety
every time
now look at this guy what he's been
eating is the equivalent of a North
American diet complete with all the fats
and sugars we regularly consume he
doesn't know where to go
his room has been damaged I don't think
that rat is unable to find the island I
think that rat is saying that Island
there's no sugar on that Island once
sugar
that's a Pixar movie waiting to happen
by the way but-but-but the sweetener
industry is not going to take the
findings of a wet confused rat lying
down they are an immensely powerful five
billion dollar industry who fought for
decades to project their products health
benefits the sugar Association used to
claim their product was a diet aid with
ads positioning it as a cure for the
fats time of day with a woman saying if
sugar can fill that hollow feeling I'm
all for it because yes nothing says I
don't feel hollow inside like a woman
sitting alone eating straight from a bag
of sugar the sugar Association has
gotten a little more sophisticated since
then here is that current president as
it relates to obesity there's been
plenty of science that exonerates sugar
the clarified sugar is not does not
contribute to obesity or diabetes really
sugar doesn't contribute to obesity I'm
not saying it's the only culprit but
it's definitely one of the key suspects
asking what causes obesity is a bit like
asking who killed a first grade classes
hamster sure they all killed it in a way
but I think we all know one of them
killed it the most I'm talking to you
Kevin you killed that hamster
and you drove your father away there I
said it Kevin I said it to be fair
take them down to be fair there are some
scientists who dismiss links between
sugars and obesity
for instance this guy we take a complex
situation like obesity and we say well
if gee if we could just cut down on
sugar sweetened beverages or added
sugars in general that would solve
obesity and I think that is a very
slippery slope and almost certainly
wrong that is dr. James rippy who like
Clamato juice turns out to contain quite
a lot of hidden sugar himself he's on
the payroll of the Corn Refiners
Association the corn syrup people and at
one point he was receiving a forty
$1,000 a month retainer from them that's
half a million dollars a year for that
much money you'd expect much grander
claims than it doesn't link to obesity
you can be say my research finds that
corn syrup makes you an immortal sex
card with x-ray vision and I'm not
saying that corporate money distorts
science but when researchers looked at
two sets of weight gain studies one
group with conflicts of interest like
funding from soda companies and one
group that was independent the vast
majority of independent studies found
direct links between sugar sweetened
soft drinks and weight gain or obesity
and the vast majority that weren't
independent found the exact opposite of
that particularly suspicious was a
research paper titled I'm so delicious
attributed to a dr. pepper regardless of
whether sugar is terrible for you or the
answer to all of life's problems
shouldn't you at least get to know when
it's being added to your food and to
their credit the FDA is trying to take
this on this week the FDA is reviewing
new nutritional labeling standards and
that may force food makers to not just
list total sugar content but how much
sugar they're adding to their products
yes the FDA is trying to get an added
sugar category onto their food labels
which is fine as long as it doesn't
distract them from forcing honeycomb
cereal to reveal what in God's name
their old mascot was
was that it look like some kind of
tumbleweeds made of merkins
but look being forced to reveal how much
sugar you are adding to people's food
might seem pretty mild but there is no
way the food manufacturing industry is
going to let that happen
the FDA has been swamped with letters
from every conceivable product from the
National yogurt Association to the
National frozen pizza Institute to
multiple representatives of the
cranberry industry now cranberries are I
think we can all agree nature's most
disgusting berry cranberries taste like
cherries who hate you cranberries taste
like what a raspberry drinks before its
colonoscopy and I think the industry
noses the head of the Ocean Spray
company wrote to the FDA saying
cranberries are naturally low in sugar
giving them a distinctly tart astringent
even unpalatable taste that's the head
of Ocean Spray describing its defining
ingredient as unpalatable it's no wonder
they want certain cranberry products to
be exempted from the proposed added
sugars declaration which is tantamount
to begging please don't make us tell
everyone how much sugar we dump on our
garbage bog berry but the most revealing
plea came from the American Beverage
Association who wrote that if there is
to be an added sugar label it must be
measured in grams and not teaspoons
because teaspoons are and I quote where
teaspoons may carry an unfair negative
connotation that undermines the factual
nature of nutrition information which is
ridiculous what negative connotation
does a teaspoon unless you think you
have an annoying dude at a diner who's
always trying to balance one on his nose
or the fact that they used to freebase
heroin but need neither of those things
is the teaspoons fault the only reason
the beverage people want sugar to be
measured in grams instead of teaspoons
is that people understand what a
teaspoon is no one understands the
metric system which is why this proposed
FDA food label is completely missing the
point because if they really want us to
understand how much sugar is in our food
they need to find our measurement we can
immediately grasp and that is why
we are proposing in the spirit of
Halloween that product manufacturers
express their sugar content in the form
of candy specifically circus peanuts the
most disgusting of all the candies they
taste like an elephant ejaculated into a
packet of Splenda and there is more than
5 grams of sugar in each one of these
horrifying things so what we're saying
to companies is this keep loading your
product products up with as much sugar
as you like on the one condition that on
the front of the packaging you display
how much sugar it contains in the form
of circus peanuts so for instance 64
ounces of Clamato juice has 88 grams of
sugar or 16 peanuts worth a can of
Campbell's tomato soup five and a half
peanuts a package of twenty circus
peanuts obviously twenty circus peanuts
that goes without saying but we as
compete consumers must demand
manufacturers adopt this measurement so
please tweet at them using the hashtag
show us your peanuts to whip out their
peanuts and present them to you
and if if they say to you we don't want
to that's embarrassing nobody wants to
see our peanuts they're orange and
misshapen and bumpy you tell them again
show us your peanuts do it food makers
expose your peanuts to the world because
if you are going to shove your peanuts
in our mouths the very least you can do
is tell us what we're swallowing
you